thank you
foreign
[Music]
joint it's popping and it sounds
something different right it's a
different sound I like to be the
flossiness of it you know I can see me
bumping it this summer I could see me
bumping oh summer hit I like that yeah I
can see that it's different it's
different it has its own sound it's
something I it's something different
something different very different okay
so it's very uh it's thinner it's laying
on his own the production is a 10. come
on
it's fun it is nice right real fun I
could see myself on a busy day in the
back of house at a kitchen just going
crazy working on orders to this keep you
hyped throughout a hard shift I like our
kitchen the veneers part is the message
is is a good tan okay it's like a good
Saturday song you could like just it's
fire though I think it was good I was
just waiting on like a big drop or
something like that you know
foreign
[Music]
okay bye
it's catchy I feel like it's definitely
a song for the summer the Reverb at the
beginning of the of the chorus the loop
of the chorus I feel like that was a
nice addition it's definitely
good material in terms of hip-hop okay
I'm I'm into like
[Music]
can I respect all music so I appreciate
that brother
[Music]
one of those right there that might be
the new phenomenon
all right man y'all know we need them
out here 100
so what is that spiritual bring it down
a little bit okay
no my Lord let's talk about veneers
oh my gosh
baby girl just wait my way I gotta see
my dinners
I like it yes
tell me what you like about it I love it
you got all your goals now you look
clean in your knees